this wildly profitable socially themed
horror comedy was one of the biggest
success stories of 2017 still it's easy
to get a little lost in all the action
and hard-hitting subtext on the screen
during the final act to help you make
sense of it all
here's get outs and being explained I'm
Roman Armitage and if you're watching
this you're probably wondering what's
going on the ultimate reveal at the end
of get out is so organically earned that
the weight of it can be hard to
understand on first viewing when Chris
goes to meet his white girlfriend roses
parents for the first time he's
apprehensive so that was a first black
guy Evan B yeah yeah so was this
uncharted territory for you know what I
want to get chase off the llama to
shotgun at first his fears seem
ridiculous since Missy and Dean seem
perfectly nice if awkward
however Dean dropped some early
foreshadowing when he reminisces about
when his father lost the race to Jesse
Owens tough break for you dead though I
almost got over as the audience in Chris
soon learned the Armitage is and their
friends are planning to steal Chris's
body as part of a plan to live forever
in the bodies of kidnapped black people
Dean's musing about his father's loss to
a black man hints early on that the
Armit edges aren't exactly as jovial as
they seem
later in the film Chris is hypnotized
against his will by Missy and introduced
to the sunken place now you're in a
sunken place
what exactly is the sunken place it's a
visual display of what happens when
Chris is paralyzed through hypnosis but
according to director Jordan Peele it
also represents the reality of living as
a marginalized person Pele tweeted we
are all in the sunken place were
marginalized no matter how hard we
scream the system silences us
unfortunately Chris soon learns that
racism is a family business and that his
girlfriend Rose is a willing participant
and her family's crimes for years she's
been luring black people back to her
family's home to be hypnotized for dark
purposes as Chris wakes up paralyzed in
a chair he finds out just how terrifying
the Armitage family really is a video
reveals that the family is part of a
cult called the order of coagula
originally led by Rosa's grandfather the
video goes on to say that the order of
coagula developed a method of life
extension through brain transplants
young black people were sought out for
these operations for the perceived
superior physical traits the black
people are lobotomized preserving only a
shadow of the hosts consciousness
forever doomed to reside as a paralyzed
passenger in its own body
their brains are replaced with the
consciousness of rich old white people
interested in immortality it's already
been established that Chris's response
to hypnosis is to panic scratch at a
chairs upholstery this winds up being
his saving grace Chris is able to pull
some cotton from the chair he's been
confined to and stuff it in his ears so
that he isn't affected by the hypnotic
sound after gaining the upper hand on
the Armitage is in a satisfyingly
violent sequence Chris gets in a car and
tries to escape in the process he comes
to a final confrontation with his former
girlfriend Rose by the end of it Rose
lies wounded on the ground telling Chris
that she still loves him
[Music]
I love you Chris sees through the lie
and begins the strangler but after their
time together he just can't bring
himself to go through with it
as he lets up on Rose we see a police
cars red and blue lights flashing
earlier in the film Rose and Chris are
pulled over despite the fact that Rose
is driving the police officer asked to
see Chris's ID and he hands it over
sadly accustomed to being profiled by
the law so when the police lights
splashed in the movies final moments we
fear that Chris will be shot or
railroaded into prison by a racist
police officer luckily it isn't a police
car but rather a TSA vehicle driven by
Chris's pal rod chris walks away from
Rose leaving her to possibly die from
her wounds and gets in Rods car finally
free from the Armitage's
twisted scheme it's a mostly happy
ending but Pele nearly ripped out
audience's hearts with an alternate
deleted ending in the alternate ending
it's not rod who turns up to save the
day
but the actual police chris is blamed
for the deaths of the Armitage house and
arrested and the scene cuts the rod
visiting Chris and prison the movie ends
with Chris accepting his fate in prison
secure in the knowledge that at least he
stopped what was happening
I stopped him you know but as Chris
hangs up the phone we can see the dozens
of black men that are in prison with him
and we know that Chris didn't really
stop anything he just stopped one
particularly fantastical symptom of
racism ultimately Pele went with that
theatrical ending because he felt like
the deleted one was just too heavy for
an audience that needed a break
he told variety that it was very clear
that the ending needed to transform into
something that gives us a hero that
gives us an escape gives us a positive
feeling when we leave this movie and get
out to the order of coagula are not the
kind of societal outcasts races that are
usually depicted in movies these are
socially accepted otherwise upstanding
citizen racists who keep their true evil
hidden by falsehoods and platitudes
please don't lump me in for that you
know I could give what color yarn by
revealing their professed admiration for
the black race as fetishistic and
opportunistic Pele revealed an unspoken
larger truth that resonated with
audiences worldwide using the
microaggressions that people of color
deal with in their everyday lives as the
signals for more sinister motives Pele
created a story that succeeds both as an
engrossing thriller and is appointed
social commentary check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]